um those these is i feel anime it's
really hard for me to find an anime that
i like and i will keep watching because
like like older again i'm just i don't
have time anymore it has to be really
good for me to stay so right now the
only thing i'm really enjoying kind of
like spikes
yeah
i think it's just like i don't know how
it's gotten so popular so quickly but i
think it's just like a show that
everyone unanimously agrees it's just
really
good yeah yeah yeah i've not heard of a
single person calling it mid and that's
like a first we're shown in anime dude
oh my god this ax is just going to be
all your for
the spy family
spy family no it's going to be the year
of genjin genshin
we were we were at mcm which is like the
british uh like uh comic-con and pretty
much every third cosplayer was against
character yeah yeah crazy how like
popular genshin is like
that's insane yes did you play genjin um
well okay so i didn't i know anything
used to and i got cast yeah i went in
this kenshin rabbit hole i was like
playing the game i was spending money i
was rolling for five star characters i
was watching genjen mmds on youtube
like it was bad
i'm like yeah i like yeah so you said
you became a full-on gention in yeah
i was like i was like that sounds normal
up until the mmd
i'm not proud of it i had a day where
i'm just like look i just did people
just the i think the models are free to
use right they like they're all right
yeah they share like the models and so
so people take the character models and
make them dance to like cute japanese
sweet songs and stuff yeah and i'm like
oh it's kind of cute and it just kept
clicking now we've literally like gone
full circle we've reverted back to like
the miku days now yeah where where you'd
have all like the old og mm mmds of like
miku characters
oh my god oh my god that was so big back
then yeah wow man
somehow genji's brought that like
[ __ ] phase back now i didn't know
yeah the nico nico era is back yeah yeah
yeah yeah so is genji in your first
gotcha game
okay so i've played lots of gotcha games
and i stopped because i have a problem
yeah um i play summoner's war for a bit
oh
that's notorious for being a money saver
wow wow
okay i'm like oh this looks really fun
let me try it and i installed it and i'm
like i need the five-star cookies and i
just keep
this it's terrible what's the
what's the most you've spent on an outro
game let's just say that i spent more
than what they paid me to voice no i was
i was about to ask is like the worst
thing that can happen to you you get
casted in the gadget game because that
means you're like obligated to play play
the game and you're gonna get really
really into it i basically paid back the
money
it's like a circular economy right
that's how that's how it works that's
just money laundering
i stopped spending money like okay i
stopped playing because i had to
uninstall like clicking around and again
yeah i find that the best way to make
sure i never play a gadget game is for
me
well yeah that but if i promote it they
give you like a cracked account right
yeah and then it just ruins the game
because you're like because then you're
like well i have everything yeah and now
there's no point in me getting my credit
card out yeah it's better
at like making enticing you to like look
at all those character demos i really
have like tons of people's jobs to just
find out what will make you most
addicted it's just it's very well done
to be fair like the characters are
beautiful the sound music everything
like i'm not a gunshin chill i swear but
like it's just really pretty like yeah
the aesthetics are nice yeah i mean like
i think there's a lot of good things
about genshin but i'm also like an ex
gentian player i've also got out i'm
i've been like one year against and free
now i'm very nasty
players
i'm i'm one year sober
i'm one of your cyber from genshin i
recently
[Music]
you need to come to more of these
therapy sessions
i played it i just never really like got
into it i kind of just played around and
i kind of had a little bit of fun yeah
it never really hooked me i think like
um the world of kenshin like surpasses
like with the actual game like people
like cosplaying it drawing it
music all of that is way stronger yeah
the community isn't community is crazy
yeah like the community is crazy and
it's like a really like tight-knit like
cool community from what i've seen as
well
and yeah but like well i think what got
me into gen chin or what saw me on genji
was actually just i don't know the
feeling it gave you like
it's like the combination of just like
the landscape and like the music was
like so [ __ ] beautiful
and like you didn't really get that in
the first area but when you discovered
leeway oh my god that's what that's when
the game actually got like good for me
you know
like but that's the exact reason those
are the exact reasons why i just opted
to play breath of the wild over against
you
because it's like it's the exact same
feeling but in my opinion the gameplay
is just way more fun it is yeah but um i
think that's a big reason why i'm like
like the cute girls almost got me they
almost got me until i saw the price tag
yeah i've already i've already completed
breath of the wild and i don't know when
the [ __ ] breath of the wild 2 is coming
out it just feels like like nice little
niche you know because ken gention is
like infinite content well it's not
really infinite content
but you know it makes you feel like it
for the last time but then you realize
it becomes like a like a part-time job
yeah that's and that's when you know
you're addicted you know anything
that'll stop me from playing league i'll
take it
league isn't that bad i swear
i still play league often not often
what why do you still want to play it
it's like it's like it's like your
ex-girlfriend
okay so you're in an abusive
relationship abusive we just like maybe
it's better if we part but then i miss
them i'm like hey what are you doing
my parents aren't home
it's like the ex-girlfriend that never
leaves the conversation out it's like
it's like yeah this is cool but my ex i
think uh moving to japan kind of killed
it for me wow because uh you the servers
suck yeah and also no one really plays
no one plays no no one plays
popular in japan
i think the least popular server but the
people on the server are just from china
and korean like smurfing
so like you don't get a game and then
when you get a game this guy who's like
apparently iron one like lee sin
perfectly like insect kicks you and
you're like
you're like all right okay [ __ ] i guess
i'm just bad also it's the most toxic
service oh it's never experienced oh my
gosh i kind of want to try this
it's just it's just because you know i
mean i feel like asians are like really
rude to each other like the different
types of asians
yes yes
and and when this and when a server is
full of people not from that country to
just like take over that country it
becomes
a talk successful yeah i think like any
other league server is toxic it's
nothing compared to the japanese servers
so uh emily and didus just moved to
japan and daida still wants to play
league and he's been sending me
screenshots of like all his chat logs
from the game yeah and it's just full on
just like people going at it yeah
arguing
like it's it's like no one on the
japanese servers speaks japanese
i've never seen japanese it's always
chinese or english
wow
oh yeah that would kill my desire too
yeah yeah so i was kind of like yeah i'm
kind of over this i just play tft now
i like tf2
but it's so it's such a bad viewer game
like
trying to get a new audience to watch
tft is is like
welcome to my algebra class three here's
a more ghana
i think it's the best but it's like a
new set just comes out that's when the
viewership i think because everyone's
like curious
yeah because i i try to like follow tft
and i have no idea what the hell is
going on so it just becomes like if if
they're streaming with a mate then it
just becomes like a glorified just
chatting stream which i i wish i could
follow you know but if it's just like
someone's streaming tft i'm like i i but
even as someone who played it a lot like
i was uh like diamond one at one point
at tft and then the next set i'm
completely clueless yeah i'm like
so it's like even if i get really really
really good in one set i'm completely
[ __ ] bad the moment they change
right everything i learned was all like
muscle memory and now i don't know
anything and now it's really hard to get
back into it do you play like uh you
play valorant or [ __ ] it
i've had to ban the word bad yes oh
i banned the wood valerian in my twitch
chat what really because i don't people
are like hey you want to play valor i'm
like don't [ __ ] ask me if i want to
play that this game [ __ ] sucks all
right let me tell my violin sucks all
right okay
all right so you join this lobby you're
locked into like an hour the game is
like an hour it's so [ __ ] like is it
an hour it's like an hour it's it's like
45 minutes
you're a little player that's like
normal no no no no that's that's a
normal amount right now but you're
always gaming in league right let's say
you join you're new it's like the worst
game to play when you're new because
it's like there's nothing to keep you
engaged you go in this game you
immediately get headshotted through a
wall by like a 12 year old korean kid
and then you're waiting watching someone
else play you're like oh dude nice dude
he carried me awesome next round you
spend you spend all your money on a gun
you go out you get shot again you're
like what the [ __ ] man let me just play
the game i know i feel like league is
the worst experience for new players
that's just me oh yeah because like
it's worse i i tried it once because
like it's horrible with valerian at
least it's a first person shooter
everyone knows how to play first
person's chapters you point around you
you click on something and then it dies
or you get killed yeah you learn it
easier yeah league is like there's how
many champions are there now yeah like
like not good like if i didn't play
league when i was like in university
there would be no way i'd be playing
league now because the learning curve
for that is [ __ ] ridiculous okay
would you play valorum if you had to
play it alone though
i play solo queue do you sometimes the
voice com is hilarious i'm like hey guys
i need mike and you're like shut the
[ __ ] up and it's just like that's such
good content that's that's fair in japan
you no one talks i you do the amount of
effort i have to do to get someone to
talk on japanese voice chat oh on apex i
can sometimes get them to talk that's so
it's like it feels like a different like
they don't talk they don't know
yeah so like like when you play like i
don't know like when you did you play
overwatch yeah like in ranked everyone
used to always talk like it was like if
you didn't have a mic you were like the
guy who's bringing the team down okay
right like and ranked but then like you
the moment i went up to japan no one
[ __ ] uses their mic ever
you have to really like they're just
really shy they are they are it's just
the culture they just don't do it like
it's just not normal to like that's why
japanese are like have really bad at
esports because they they don't talk
they don't communicate they're
communicating moms are weak dude watch
japanese esports teams they're just like
silent
it was a was it the ballarat japanese
team what's it called they're pretty
correct they're insane they're very good
yeah okay yeah i don't follow the
japanese or the valerian esports scene
unfortunately only league that's enough
for me but they don't talk to each other
probably i don't know probably just like
telepathy or something [ __ ]